déçu quand même temps choquer mais on en
est rendus de faux tableaux de l'artiste
peintre dominic besner ont été mises à
l'encan sur internet et ils ont été
vendus au quart du prix d'un vrai besner
c'est chacun un peu pour les personnes
de les collectionneurs qui ont cru
acheter un bestiaire dans mon cas et
qu'en bout de ligne se sont fait flouer
nous les coulisses aussi découler stress
et après avoir analysé les deux faux
tableaux que le directeur studio de
l'artiste a dû annoncer aux nouveaux
acheteurs qui croyait avoir mis la main
sur des originaux que les oeuvres
étaient des copies des boucs chose qui
qui fait pas les formes au sort c'est
comme ça j'ai vérifié pour ça que tu
talent aussi dans l'atelier du regretté
marcel barbeau minot gauthier se désole
de voir défaut barbot à vente sur
internet pour une bouchée de pain
c'est choquant aussi parce que il ya des
gens qui essaient de faire un peu
d'argent avec son nom en imitant ses
oeuvres et en trahissant il accorder la
même importance
le faux dans le monde de l'art a
toujours existé et plus un artiste à la
cote
et puis les copier au québec marc aurèle
fortin jean paul lemieux et
jean-paul-riopelle sont parmi les
artistes peintres les plus contrefaits
les copies de ces artistes là et a pas
fait ici mais y est à faire en chine
plus abordable est fait par un grande
échelle moi je vois des choses à acheter
sur ebay des bons duos où il manque l es
à bord du vol c'est assez clair que
quelqu'un qui est un peu un
collectionneur ou faire un minimum de
recherche s'attend pas à voir une vraie
bombe
comment tu arrives avec 30 g pain le
propriétaire de la galerie mx pense que
le problème demeure marginal et qu'il
peut être réglé
c'est l'industrie se mettaient d'accord
ensemble tous les joueurs des galeristes
artistes ils devraient enfin enregistrer
leurs tableaux par un agent sous le
mental ou quoi que ce soit donc ça
qu'après tout défaut ça qu'après la
vente au noir est mai
en ce qui concerne les tableaux de
dominic besner chaque oeuvre est
numéroté il est donc facile d'identifier
un tableau contrefaits ici une oeuvre
que l'on dit original et vendus à très
bas prix sur internet
cette offre est peut-être trop belle
pour être vraie pour le prix que se sont
vendus oui le peut-être un peu anglais
sourd je n'ai pas eu assez
d'informations qui étaient reliés avec
l'oeuvre pour être remis aux
collectionneurs
les deux acheteurs défaut besner
attendent toujours d'être remboursée
parlant compteur qui a effectué la
transaction ici louis philippe ouimet
radio canada montréal